[Música]
bom
imagino que todos vocês já tenha ouvido
é aquela expressão em casa de ferreiro
espeto de pau na vida ela aparece
geralmente quando percebemos que alguns
cardiologistas fumam e quando a gente
pensa nesses profissionais que vêm à
nossa cabeça primeira coisa é você
precisar de um cardiologista
eu nunca vou me consultar com eles e
porque a gente julga dessa forma
bom nós jogamos dessa forma porque
estamos todos nós
sob o efeito de uma droga que se chama
soma parece estranho né
mas deixa eu explicar o soma um
admirável mundo novo de aldous huxley
era uma pílula que era entregue para
todos os habitantes de uma sociedade
aparentemente perfeita para que eles
tomassem e fossem felizes felizes o
tempo todo no nosso admirável mundo novo
os homo ele vem em forma de um discurso
o discurso do sonho americano essa
ditadura de sucesso e da felicidade
essa dita essa ditadura que disse que a
gente tem que ser sempre mais
nós temos que ser mais bonitos nós temos
que ser mais inteligentes
nós temos que ser mais interessantes
para que a gente esteja acima dos outros
para isso nós temos que ser melhores
melhores na escola para depois
conseguimos entrar nas melhores
universidades para depois a gente
conseguir os melhores empregos nas
melhores empresas ganharmos os maiores
salários e temos uma carreira de sucesso
nós também buscamos uma vida em uma
sociedade perfeita
nós queremos ter
família perfeita como os filhos
perfeitos um cachorro perfeito uma casa
grande
dois carros na garagem e depois a gente
troca por mais dois e assim por diante
e pra gente conseguir todas essas coisas
a gente parte para o mundo do trabalho
acreditando que tudo é possível né
é só você querer acreditar pensar
positivo e seguir em frente
quem já leu esses 10 seller de autoajuda
ou já assistiu essas palestras dos gurus
da positividade sabe do que eu estou
falando
mas o que eles não nos dizem é que esse
agente nega o sofrimento as tristezas o
fracasso
nós não nos tornamos feliz
na verdade acontece justo o contrário e
é nessa hora que o soma começa a mostrar
os seus efeitos colaterais
qual é o maior deles é a depressão
segundo a organização mundial da saúde
de 2005 pra cá nós tivemos um aumento de
quase 20 por cento nos casos de
depressão no mundo inteiro aqui no
brasil 5,8 por cento da população foi
diagnosticada com depressão
isso dá mais de 11 milhões de pessoas
aqui nas américas nós perdemos apenas
para os estados unidos que são cerca de
5,9 por cento da população ou mais de 17
milhões de pessoas que agora no ano que
vem
em 2020 a depressão vai ser a doença
mais incapacitante em todo o planeta
bom vocês lembram da expressão em casa
de ferreiro espeto de pau
pois bem eu edson e psicólogo
fiz parte dessas estatísticas e eu vou
contar pra vocês o que eu aprendi nesse
processo eu também como um habitante
desse admirável mundo novo
eu me rendi os encantos de soma
na minha versão do sonho americano eu
seria um psicólogo de sucesso que iria
mudar o mundo
eu teria dinheiro fama e reconhecimento
e aí a cada dia mais cada vez mais eu
poderia ajudar mais e mais pessoas a
conquistarem a própria saúde mental e
pra isso eu seria psicólogo clínico mas
em um dado momento na faculdade eu te ir
para a área de organizações trabalhar
com a regra de empresas
eu imaginei que eu poderia ganhar mais
dinheiro no início fazendo essa mudança
você imagina o que aconteceu a melhor ea
pior coisa que poderia ter me acontecido
o sucesso
no começo eu tinha a melhor parte do
soma eu conhecer pessoas interessantes
eu desenvolvi as minhas habilidades eu
me senti importante eu me sentia
especial
eu me sentia útil nessa época eu sentia
que a minha vida é realmente tinha
sentido
sabe aquele sentido que parece preencher
de alguma forma aquele incômodo vazio
existencial que todos nós temos é a
minha carreira foi se desenvolvendo
assim eu fui recebendo promoções e
aumentos de salário e também aumento de
atividades
eu fazia contratações desde estagiários
até cientistas brasileiros e
estrangeiros
e eu também fazia as atividades de
treinamento desenvolvimento escrever
políticas e programas de rh
chega um momento que eu percebi que eu
trabalhava em quase todas as horas em
que eu estivesse acordado em um dia eu
cheguei a dormir na empresa
mas é claro que ninguém podia saber é
porque imagina o cara de rh que pega no
red todo mundo pra ninguém fazer hora
extra a bola domínio da empresa
quebrei a regra e aí num dia numa seção
minha terapia
pois é gente se cobra também
fazem terapia viu a minha analista no
final da sessão ela chegou e perguntou
edson e aí que você faz depois do
trabalho
eu levei aquele choque porque eu percebi
que a minha vida era o trabalho e eu já
tinha perdido o contato com a minha
família eu recusava todos os convites
dos meus amigos para sair e eu percebi
que eu tinha perdido quase que
totalmente o contato com o mundo fora do
trabalho porque não sabia naquela época
ainda que também já tinha perdido a
conexão comigo mesmo por fora a naval a
tim e por dentro tudo já começava a
desmoronar nessa época soma começava a
mostrar agora os efeitos colaterais mas
eu ainda queria mais
foi quando uma multinacional inglesa me
oferecer uma oportunidade de trabalhar
em uma de suas bases em são paulo eu
deveria reestruturar toda a área de
recursos humanos deles
então mudei de campinas onde morava para
são paulo capital e por um ano eu fiz o
meu melhor
trabalhei duro eu dei tudo que eu tinha
finalmente a área de recursos humanos
estava reestruturado
eu já tinha criado um vínculo de afeto
com as pessoas que trabalhavam comigo
fiz várias amizades até que um dia tudo
desmoronou
a empresa decidiu fechar essa nossa base
em são paulo
o que eu deveria fazer deveria demitir
todo mundo e depois de emitir a mesma
que foi que eu fiz foram 98 demissões 98
olhares desconsolados e 98 conversas
se eu pudesse eu nunca gostaria de ter
como toda moeda tem seus dois lados né
seu audi também foi o meu fundo do poço
eu estava desempregado estava cansado
estava totalmente esgotado
eu carregava no peito aquela sensação de
vazio e um fracasso
eu não tinha mais forças então para
continuar
eu decidi parar e refletir
nessa época decidi tirar um ano sabático
o meu plano inicial era sair do país
para viver em uma comunidade de ter uma
cultura ao mesmo tempo em que eu
aprenderia com a natureza e com a terra
e também aprender um novo idioma era o
meu sonho é que vocês nem imaginam aonde
que eu fui parar no sábado e foi aí que
jaraguá do sul a cidade que respira
trabalho
eu recebi um convite do meu primo pra
passar um tempo no sítio dos nossos avós
para acompanhar uma reforma e ajudar
minhas duas tias idosas estão lá
trabalhou novamente né na estrada
levando a minha malinha cheia de roupas
e o meu coração ainda cheio de vazio é
só que dessa vez era diferente né porque
não tinha mais aquela pílula do soma no
meu organismo
eu não tinha mais opções eu não tinha
mais cobranças e não tinha mais aquela
loucura daquele desejo de sucesso também
eu pensei e aí se tudo der errado
se tudo der errado parte pro meu plano
original saiu do país para viver em uma
comunidade de permacultura mas não deu
errado
tudo deu certo e da maneira mais
inesperada presídio
as minhas tias foram muito generosos
elas me ensinaram tudo que elas sabiam
sobre o trabalho e sobre a terra e aí a
minha versão de comer rezar e amar
foi capinar girar a terra jogar a
semente pegar esterco de gado jogar e
esperar a planta nascer depois dela se
desenvolver depois ela se tornará
alimento e aí eu percebi que eu tinha
capacidade de amar porque a saúde mental
é isso a nossa capacidade de amar e
trabalhar esse conceito do freud o
criador da psicanálise é o conceito que
eu mais gosto porque ele fala de
equilíbrio
amar é saber lidar com a falta em si e
no outro ia saber que a gente não tem
como preencher esse vazio existencial
na verdade a justiça esse vazio que nos
faz desejar e agir
aprendi que não a lavoura sem trabalho e
sem dor
aprendi que não a lavoura sem frustração
porque nem toda semente ela germina num
canteiro e também numa lavoura sem
paciência porque as coisas não acontecem
no tempo que a gente quer
sem 30 que a gente quer e foi assim
então sem eu nem perceber que eu já
tinha criado um significado novo
trabalho na minha vida eu não me
importava mais um resultado agora estava
importando realmente em aproveitar todo
o caminho e quando o meu período
sabático chegou ao fim e eu voltei a
trabalhar agora finalmente como
psicólogo químico mas sem aquele desejo
megalomaníaco de mudar o mundo
eu já tinha a minha lavoura já tinha
alimentado a mim e as minhas tias e
várias outras pessoas as quais nós
compartilhávamos e eu também tinha
aprendido uma nova maneira de me
comunicar
quando eu conheci alguém agora eu
chegava pessoa perguntava e aí você
gosta de repolho
o que era uma das coisas que eu plantava
eu adorava compartilhar eu me sentia
feliz e hoje vocês me perguntam edson
depois de estudo do cf eles
bom eu tenho meus momentos felizes né
eles dividem espaço com as minhas
inseguranças com as incertezas como
vazio
acho que assim como todo mundo eu
recusei o soma mas não soma ele sempre
reverberam no nosso corpo
quando eu recebi o convite para
palestrar nesse tex foi um desses
momentos que soma reverberou novamente
primeiro me senti extremamente honrado
especial por ter sido com um convidado é
o tecido escolhido depois ver aquela
insegurança que começa a tomar conta
dominei aceitei o convite e veio a parte
de criação
imagina o que acontece se você quer
fazer um trabalho perfeito vem aquela
angústia né escreve escreve escreve joga
papel fora não sai nada se fala nossa
senhora não devia ter aceitado mas
aceitei então segue em frente
um desses momentos de uma angústia maior
eu paralisei eu falei 'não peraí preciso
sair dá uma volta e respirar e foi
quando eu dei uma volta na minha horta e
ali parado no meio da horta olhando
todas aquelas plantas entre o céu ea
terra aquela calmaria com o som dos
pássaros passou por mim uma borboleta
azul
nesse momento eu me senti feliz
verdadeiramente feliz por estar vivo e
eu acordei e é isso que eu vim dizer
aqui pra vocês hoje estarmos vivos
acordados em conexão com nós mesmos
os outros é o melhor que nós podemos
fazer
vocês também podem recusar o soma no
começo é difícil e desafiador
dá aquele frio na barriga dá medo
em alguns momentos a gente se sente
perdido
parece impossível mas não é
vocês vão conseguir e quando o período
de abstinência passar
vocês vão perceber exatamente o que eu
percebi que a única pílula que nós
precisamos para viver
nós nos sentimos bem conosco e com as
pessoas ao nosso redor é a presença
sutil e passageira de uma borboleta azul
obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]